la séparation est confirmée alexei doux et
la séparation physique confirme s'il vous plaît
surveiller tous les paramètres oui copie donc
encore une fois le vaisseau spatial Soyouz désamarré oleg
kononenko de'vide st.  jacques et anne
mcclain volent maintenant librement de la
station spatiale pour la première fois en 204 jours se
préparant pour la brûlure une minute 30
secondes dans maintenant Soyouz continuant à
reculer se désamarrant de ce module poison
en attente pour la brûlure de séparation numéro
un ce sera environ un  8 secondes de tir
de propulseurs à bord du vaisseau spatial
semblant jusqu'à présent terminés à l'heure d'atterrissage
ciblés en ce moment à 948